we can choose to believe that superstorm
sandy and the most severe drought in
decades and the worst wildfires some
states have ever seen we're all just a
freak coincidence or we can choose to
believe in the overwhelming judgment of
science and act before it's too late the
extent of environmental damage from
manmade climate change is a debate in
and of itself but President Obama has
made it clear there will be some form of
government action during his second term
if Congress won't act soon to protect
future generations I will no idea is
gaining more traction or causing more
concern than a carbon tax this would be
a tax on each ton of carbon dioxide
emitted into the atmosphere from the
burning of fossil fuels like oil and
coal advocates argue that this would be
a good market friendly tax that wouldn't
tank the economy but is this really the
case
well a carbon tax would do exactly what
you want it to do which is to
incorporate the damages to the
environment into the prices we pay for
all manner of goods and services
Adele Morris of the Brookings
Institution says that existing
regulations under the Clean Air Act are
obsolete ineffective and even harmful
Morris has studied different carbon tax
models and says that this might be a
better alternative right now because
carbon is not priced we have an implicit
advantage to traditional energy that's
inefficient in an ideal world if carbon
emissions were in fact directly harming
someone's property the government should
step in and make sure that they get
compensated the problem is the
transactions cost the cost of trying to
get those damages through the court
system are just too high and so maybe
what you need is a carbon tax as a
substitute for that process Reason
magazine science correspondent Ronald
Bailey says that while a carbon tax
could help pay for private property
damages it has to be constructed and
executed very carefully the right way to
do a carbon tax if we had decided we
wanted to go down that path would be a
one-for-one offset with other
taxes probably the payroll tax would be
the best way to do it or another way you
might do it is at the end of the year
when you collect it up all the taxes
that the government would divide it up
and send a check to every American for
their share of that tax exactly a carbon
tax doesn't have to be just for raising
new revenue for new spending if you made
it revenue neutral it would help with
the concern that all you're doing is
adding more burdens on that to the
American economy but even if the tax
revenues make it back to the taxpayers
it would still drive up the cost of
goods and services because businesses
would have to foot the bill
any dollar that the government takes
from us by way of a tax is the dollar
that we can't put back into our
factories Nick Castle works for
Morningstar one of the world's largest
tomato processing plants he says that
Morningstar and other food processors
would most likely have to pass on the
cost of the tax to their customers
there's no secret bag of money that any
business has in a bottom drawer you're
creating value you're deriving value
from your resources the more you can
limit the use of resources and create
value is margin so that margin is is the
incentive that keeps businesses running
effectively and cost-effectively and
doing everything they can
the amount of carbon emissions for each
product likely wouldn't change because
right now there isn't a good alternative
to fossil fuels so that leaves two
options to cut total emissions either
prices go up or production goes down the
consequences in terms of economic growth
would be could be quite severe depending
on the level you set the tax on it will
certainly slow things down in the sense
that it makes all fuels more expensive
what we found a carbon tax could be
disproportionately
burdening lower-income households
because they spend a relatively larger
share of their income on energy gasoline
home heating that kind of thing one
option would be to embed a carbon tax
into a broader fiscal package such that
the regressivity of the
carbon tax could be counterbalanced by
other parts of that package that are
progressive a lot of people fear what
would happen is once you establish a
carbon tax basically they wouldn't
return it to the public they wouldn't
return it as a rebate to taxpayers or as
a reduction at one-for-one reduction in
their payroll taxes instead it would
just be another tax so you would
increase government spending you would
slow down the economy and you would have
less leave less money in the pockets of
the the working people of America and if
prices get too high people would start
to look elsewhere for cheaper products
like China I was just in China and June
when you drive through that country you
can see examples of strip-mining
clear-cutting
I mean it's blatant disregard for the
environment the United States uses the
energy to produce a g-dog GDP much more
efficiently than either China or India
does so if you're moving an activity
from the United States over to China and
India they're very likely to use a lot
more energy to produce the same product
that you could have produced with less
energy here at home
thus harming the environment overall
seeing as a fully enforced worldwide
carbon tax isn't realistic is a carbon
tax still our best option to reduce
emissions I think they're going to be a
number of unpalatable choices and the
question is could a carbon tax feature
into a set of choices that that creates
space for for an overall deal I think it
could the cost of implementing
government policy may be a lot higher
than the benefits that you're going to
try to get out of them so you have to be
very careful about that a clean simple
carbon tax rebating all the money back
to individual Americans that might work
but anything more complicating that is
very likely to cost a lot more than the
benefits that we could hope to get out
of it politics do complicate things and
betting on a clean simple carbon tax is
very risky the best way to stimulate
innovation is through market
competitiveness the more competition you
have in the free market the more
incentive there is for a businessperson
and a business
to do what it can to gain market share
and grow we are already running as
efficient as we believe being the most
price competitive producer in the world